well i officially returned to my show
from vacation today which means that in
preparation for this event i had to make
my official return
to twitter yesterday i had only ventured
you know back into that overflowing
cyber septic tank for a few hours before
my name was trending and i thought that
at first you know i was trending because
everybody was welcoming and being back
with well wishes and warm salutations
and all that but it turns out that um
most of the messages were considerably
less
friendly i guess that's no surprise on
second thought the conversation seemed
to revolve around a brief argument that
i had with jk rowling on sunday because
of course the first thing that i do when
i come back from vacation and i'm really
well rested is i i pick a fight with a
random famous person but before we get
to that we need to back up
all the way to ancient history which was
last tuesday when i was still out
fishing and the singer macy gray was
igniting a media
firestorm by controversially suggesting
that women exist
so during her appearance on piers morgan
where i think she was promoting an album
or something like that she uh the the
conversation kind of drifted to the
topic of gender and morgan
posed the ultimate question of course
the question of our generation which um
uh gray had at first no trouble
answering at all
i'm sure you've heard this this clip
already but uh let's play it again just
for our own enjoyment here it is
if i asked you what a woman is what
would you say
i would say uh a human being with uh
boobs
how are you to start there yeah i mean
the dictionary is quite straightforward
it just says
adult female right
now a lot of people yeah see that's now
that's a little getting confusing the
whole he
they that's good that's good and i'm not
sure why really it's it's a bit like
this whole issue of of transgenders in
sport it's like i support all trans
rights to fairness and equality
but not where you have people born to
obvious physical superior bodies
transitioning and then thrashing the
women at their sport i totally agree and
i will say this and everybody's going to
hate me but as a woman
just because you go change your parts
doesn't make you a woman right sorry
you feel that
i know that for a fact like if you want
me to call you or her i will because
that's what you want but that doesn't
make you a woman just cause i call you
or her and just because you got a
surgery
so
thus began the usual circus routine
after saying this objectively true and
normal thing
gray was reviled by the left slammed as
a transphobe and a bigot and she's you
know well she's she's marginalizing and
erasing trans people
through her refusal to allow women to be
marginalized and erased that's basically
the accusation and meanwhile on the
other side of it the the right hailed
her as a hero you know a courageous
warrior triumphing over cancel culture
she was applauded for for standing firm
and and being bold in the face of the
backlash
but the applause
as is almost always the case
unfortunately came too soon uh gray made
it all of about three days
before buckling and on thursday of the
very same week the singer made the
traditional pilgrimage to a morning tv
show to express her deep regrets and
sorrow and to beg for absolution she
explained that over the previous couple
of days the experience of having a bunch
of blue-haired freaks scream screaming
at her had been very educational and it
had been very enlightening she'd learned
a lot from the blue haired freaks that's
my words not hers i'm paraphrasing in
fact she learned that
everything she thought she knew about
the world was wrong biology is a myth
and that she as a woman
doesn't actually exist she learned all
this in two or three days
and they had taught her this
by crying and screaming it was the most
educational temper tantrum she'd ever
witnessed apparently let's watch that i
never of course meant to hurt anybody
with with what i said i'm not
i'm actually a huge uh
i think it takes a lot of courage to be
yourself to to go out in the world and
be honest about who you are
and uh so i think anyone who is uh
in the lgbt community is a hero and sets
an example for all of us with that you
know
um
so i said some things uh that that uh
didn't go over well
but um my intention was never to to hurt
anybody i feel bad uh
that i did hurt some people
and and i think it's it's um
you know it's just about education it's
about conversation and and us getting to
a point where we
understand each other and and um
and and that that only happens with you
know i've learned a lot through this
so i think that that was one of the
reasons uh it might have happened just
it was a huge learning experience for me
you know what i i think you you you can
like i said in there you can call
yourself what like you you whoever you
believe you are and and no one can
dictate that for you or take that away
from you you know
i think life is an education process the
more you sit with people the more you
talk to people it changes your
perspective so has has your perspective
changed do you feel
i've learned so much and and i think um
you know being a woman is a vibe and
it's something i'm i'm very proud of
and it's very precious to me and and
i i think that if you
in your heart feel that that's what you
are then that's what you are regardless
of what anybody says
or thinks you know what i'm saying
well it's a good thing you know that all
the groveling bases were covered there
she didn't skip any of the steps she was
very thorough in that way the script was
followed with precision
uh and and though we we've grown so
accustomed to seeing this pageant of
humiliation play out it never gets any
easier to watch at least not for me
anyway each time i feel like i'm
watching somebody cut their own heart
out of their chest it's grotesque and
disgusting and humiliating but weirdly
fascinating you're just kind of glued to
the screen watching this
sick display um and you you can't look
away as much as you want to because we
know the steps here step one
the penitent
claims that she's learned a lot and
she's been educated that's the necessary
first step never explains what she's
learned exactly or how she learned it or
exactly what insights her critics
offered to her that's because there was
there was no insight unless guttural
screaming and demonic convulsing counts
as an insight i don't know and then step
two she she flatters the rage mob you
know she lays down her offerings at
their feet
she bows before them in worship adoring
them declaring in this case that
everybody in the lgbt community is a
hero all of them
because um of course it requires true
heroism
to belong to the most protected
privileged and coddled and applauded
group of people to ever exist on planet
earth that requires heroism to do that
and then step three she finally and
fully renounces all of her past beliefs
she renounces reality and truth itself
she renounces renounces her own
existence really
proclaiming that contrary to what she
had always thought up until about
breakfast time that morning there is no
objective or biological basis to
womanhood
being a woman is as she put it
a vibe
you know it's just a vibe a woman isn't
anything but you know if you feel like
you are one
then you are one and what you are
is nothing
all women are nothing
and everybody is invited to join them in
their nothingness
now of course
if being a woman is just a vibe
then it doesn't really make a lot of
sense for men to take drugs or get
surgeries as part of their transition
process
there is no such thing as a vibe surgery
you can't surgically implant or remove a
vibe right you can't go to the doctor
and say uh you know i i just i want to
have a certain vibe can you give me a
cert that doesn't make any sense
if it's all about the vibe if it's about
the feeling then the whole gender
transition industry
makes no sense and it's built on a false
premise so it turns out that either way
whether the claims made by gender
ideology are wrong or right
the whole process of gender transition
is nonsensical and false either way
but as we've learned we cannot expect
the proponents of this idea to notice
these kinds of contradictions or care
about them if they do notice them
this all brings us back to the beginning
of our story i criticized
macy gray for you know on twitter for
being a gutless coward which is what she
is
and after some pushback to that i
tweeted this i said sorry but women who
publicly renounce the definition of
woman for fear of mean comments from
trans activists deserve all the scorn
they get that kind of gutless cowardice
is exactly what got us into this
position in the first place that's what
i said okay
now a little while later jk rowling who
famously has stood up courageously
against the trans mob uh responded to me
with a defense of gray and of other
women who have similarly folded like
cheap lawn chairs
rowling tweeted in response to me she
said
endless death threats and rape threats
threats of loss of livelihood employers
targeted physical harassment family
addresses posted online with pictures of
bomb making manuals aren't mean comments
if you don't yet understand what happens
to women who stand up on this issue back
off
she said talking to me
now lots of other feminists in the
so-called turf camp or the gender
critical camp as they prefer to call
themselves most of them they've echoed
and agreed with this sentiment from
rowling in fact um
i've heard this from feminists
quite a lot since my film came out that
that it's easy for me they say i don't
know what it's like
okay
i don't have to make the same kind of
sacrifices i don't put the same things
on the line i don't get treated the same
way
nobody attacks me the way they attack
women who speak out
and now rowling whose courage on this
issue i as i said i really respect and
i've said that many times
is singing the same tune
but she's completely wrong of course
and it just shows how feminists who
criticize the trans agenda
even though they're right about the
issue of transgenderism they're still
hamstrung and handicapped by left-wing
identity politics and victimology
they can't accept an alliance
with a man because they resent us for
our perceived privilege
even though it's a privilege they've
completely invented in their heads
because the fact is that nearly
everything she describes
the things that i can't understand
supposedly because they only happen to
women supposedly
they have happened to me with great
frequency and ferocity i would say over
the past month and before that but
especially over the past month
i've had many death threats i've been
doxed many times
okay i don't i don't the thing is i
don't talk about these things a lot i
mention them here and there i don't
spend a lot of time talking about them
but i can assure you they are happening
uh i've been threatened
harassed insulted they've tried to
de-platform me they tried to get me
fired they tried to get my advertisers
the boy copy etc and so forth over and
over and over again
i don't doubt
at all
that trans activists are vicious
monsters towards any woman who defies
them but the operative aspect there is
defies them
not women
they cannot tolerate defiance from
anyone
the survival of their fragile worldview
as we've seen depends on
silencing all of the opposition no
matter who it's coming from
doesn't matter if it's the idea that
if it's coming from a from a white
conservative man that they're gonna lay
off no he's good he's one of the good
ones let's leave him alone
it's just uh it's hilarious
but here's the thing
if i had over the past month or any if i
any time in the future
cave to the mob and pull a macy gray
i would deserve scorn too endless
amounts of it okay i i would i'm telling
you right now if i ever were to do that
you should scorn me and despise me for
that
now it's not going to happen happen i
can assure you that
because i would quite literally rather
be dead than surrender to these people
i'd rather take a bullet to the head
than debase myself the way macy gray did
and it wouldn't even be a difficult
choice
but if that were not the case and i
crumbled under the onslaught and turned
traitor on truth for the sake of
protecting myself i would be i would be
uh a a worse villain in this story
than any individual trans militant
because as i said in the original tweet
the cowards are the ones who got us into
this mess
why is that well
because there were never enough and
still are not enough trans militants to
forcibly drag our society into the mass
epidemic of madness that we're currently
experiencing they can't do it on their
own
without our consent as much as they
would like to as much as they're trying
to they can't
in order for this to happen it has it
has required and will continue to
require the acquiescence of countless
people who know better who know the
truth
but implicitly or in many cases
explicitly renounce and disavow that
knowledge in order to preserve their own
comfort and their own safety but most of
the time it's just their own comfort
because most of the time their safety is
not really in jeopardy sometimes it is
but in most cases it's not
you know i really don't think that
anyone was gonna go kill macy gray
because of uh because of a you know a
one-minute conversation she had on piers
morgan
i wouldn't put anything past these
people but i really doubt that was going
to happen
what she was trying to protect was her
financial security and just her comfort
and and really she just wanted to get
along with her hollywood friends and her
friends in the music industry and that's
what she was trying to protect
every time a coward collapses like this
betraying themselves and all the rest of
us on the team common you know on team
common sense when they when they when we
are betrayed in this way as we are so
often
they only make it that much harder for
whoever the mob turns its sights on next
so it's not a victimless
crime here
the mob is emboldened and fueled by
every person who sells their souls to it
they are vultures who feed on the
dignity that you abandon and leave on
the floor
they they feast on your subservience
and your submission
and your self-debasement
the only way to stop them is to starve
them of this fuel
is to look them in the eyes and say no i
apologize for nothing i am right you are
wrong
now go scream about it some more you
damned hobgoblins i don't care they
don't scare me
and laugh in their face that's how you
handle it
anything less than that
and you're part of the problem well i
hope you enjoyed that clip from that
wall show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this youtube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts